le tour de france des rails les coureurs
ont refusé de faire l'état certains ont
abandonné ils protestent contre la
poursuite des enquêtes sur le dopage des
perquisitions les conditions de leur
interrogatoire
invité de ce journal richard virenque en
direct de genève il a gardé le silence
depuis son exclusion et l'exclusion de
son équipe il y a onze jours pour
réduire le déficit de la sécurité
sociale martine aubry annonce une série
de mesures visant les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et les médecins
spécialistes deux milliards sept
d'économies à trouver le président bill
qui nous donne en difficulté manica les
mains ce qui a obtenu l'immunité
judiciaire pour témoigner de sa relation
sexuelle présumée avec le président des
états unis madame monsieur bonsoir
après une échappée de 48 heures dans les
alpes les affaires de dopage ont
rattrapé les coureurs du tour de france
en apprenant que d'autres perquisitions
auraient lieu ce soir dans les hôtels de
plusieurs équipes
les coureurs ont décidé de ne pas faire
l'état ils ont roulé au pas des gras
font leurs dossards certaines équipes
ont même abandonné comme celle de
laurent jalabert
une journée comme on n'en avait jamais
vu sur le tour et ce soir à l'arrivée à
aix les bains
et bien c'est l'avenir du tour 98 qui
est en cause florent gautreau à la
praille sur toutes les bouches le
ras-le-bol dans tous les regards le
doute
le coureur de tdm tchekhov raconte à
pantani sa nuit passée à l'hôpital
les coureurs et zic mais finalement
démarre départ fictif un départ qui
n'aura jamais aussi bien porté son nom
car il n'y aura jamais de départ réel
sur les rives du lac d'annecy c'est le
temps de la rumeur à 20 km/heure
s'arrêter ou ne pas s'arrêter
telle est la question au km 32 la
décision est prise
le peloton s'arrête
attraper par les affaires à coire qui a
pas été massés hier soir qui après bien
pu se changer récupérer ces couches à
2h30 du matin c'est pas très bon pour
l'alcool donc disons que ça allait
pénaliser donc on avait décidé de rouler
tranquille en guise de solidarité et la
gc puis tout s'arrête je comprends
purement c'est le grand flou cet arrêt
improvisé à saint jorioz est le fruit de
la colère d'une partie des coureurs
les perquisitions récurrente dans les
hôtels les interrogatoires de police
tout cela a choqué le peloton cinq jours
après la grève de tarascon la colère
gronde à nouveau ça va y avoir des plus
mal que certains violeurs
et ça c'est indécent moi on est là avant
tout pour faire rêver les gens
et puis les gens les gens exposés se
posent des questions mais ils savent
plus qui arrivent et ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait ce qu'on fait au tour de france est
ce qu'on fait on pourra en général mes
genoux nouvelle fois tout le monde n'est
pas sur la même longueur d'onde luc
leblanc qui veut s'arrêter se heurte à
un coupé 2 portes annick qui lui
souhaita noir notre pris leur décision
jalabert et l'équipe on sait sont déjà
en voiture direction l'hôtel à
aix-les-bains celle abordons un peu plus
loin l'équipe banesto quittera la course
elle aussi les autres équipes
choisissent de repartir sans vraiment
savoir pour combien de temps la course
est neutralisée et certains coureurs
symboliquement arrachent leurs dossards
des équipes hors de la course des
coureurs qui ne souhaitent pas être
classée il n'ya plus d'étapes le tour
est en danger
ce cas c'est la policière à tvm je ne
trouve pas ça correct
tout le monde a des droits il faut les
respecter il faut qu'on soit solidaires
dans le peloton je ne sais pas ce que
les autres pensent qu'ils vont faire
mais moi je crois qu'on ne peut pas
arrêter le tour de france nouveau
rebondissement au kilomètre 46 bjarne
riis intronisé porte parole des coureurs
s'entretient avec jean marie leblanc le
danois prévient le directeur de
l'épreuve
le peloton va à nouveau s'arrêter pour
discuter riis vainqueur du tour en 96
explique alors aux coureurs qu'il a reçu
des garanties
la société du tour a négocié avec les
autorités judiciaires pour que les
auditions de cyclistes si audition il ya
se déroule calmement et dans les hôtels
des équipes bernerie se disait peut-être
que cette étape aujourd'hui ne comptera
pas ce devra être annulée mais
assurément si nous obtenons sa loge
iront jusqu'à paris je crois que c'est
aujourd'hui ce qui compte
prioritairement c'est que le tour puisse
s'achever à paris avec un vainqueur avec
des lauréats avec une apothéose aller au
bout si le public le permis dans le
premier col des spectateurs mécontents
gêne la progression des coureurs la
course subi un nouveau coup d'arrêt
finalement le public et les coureurs
retrouveront la sérénité nécessaire pour
finir c'est interminable étape une fin
symbolique ce sont les tvm mise en cause
par la justice qui franchissent la ligne
en tête avec la permission du peloton
bonsoir vous êtes à aix les bains vous
avez vécu au milieu au milieu du peloton
en direct cet après midi les différents
évènements de cette étape annulée
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment comme
nous que l'avenir de ce tour 98 au moins
est en cause ce soir on peut se poser
très franchement la question oui on peut
se poser la question et non pas de la
part des organisateurs n'ont pas de la
part de l'union cycliste internationale
mais tout simplement de la part des
coureurs les plus que jamais il y a eu
un gros coup de colère de la part des
coureurs un gros mélange de tristesse
d'irritation contre tout ce qui s'est
passé la nuit dernière et plus que le
fond de la faire c'est la forme qui leur
plaît pas parce que les témoignages
qu'on a pu recueillir toute la journée à
la fois au moment où ils ont mis pied à
terre là au fameux km 32 à saint jorioz
zh et il disait à ce moment là oui pour
les contrôler oui pour l' enquête
policière mais pas dans ces formes là
car reprenant l'expression de laurent
jalabert nous sommes pas du bétail et
nous ne sommes pas des délinquants
s'il vous plaît messieurs les les
justiciers messieurs les policiers
prenaient des formes
nous ne vous comportez pas un peu comme
des cow boys c'est ce qui ressortait de
la journée et puis l'homme qui a été le
grand diplomate de la journée celui qui
a permis sans doute à ce que l'état
paillasson terme et peut-être même à ce
que le tour et jusqu'aux champs-elysées
il est à côté de moi c'est bien en à
risque car il a pris les choses en main
quand j'allais faire les choses en main
bien brice disais tout à l'heure je
crois en direct chez vous que si ce soir
il y avait des perquisitions il y à des
perquisitions et bien demain les
coureurs ne reprendrai pas la course
william pardon vous n'aviez vous les
entendez la question daniel daniel
bilalian dit tout à l'heure vous avez 10
il y à des perquisitions dans les dans
les hôtels ce soir on ne reprendra pas
la course
est-ce que vous pouvez commenter ça mais
je pense on le sait bien que
et peut-être on va voir quelques
policiers dans donc dans quelques hôtels
mais on m'a donné la parole que je vais
faire voyez un mal aucune coureurs et si
c'est vrai ça va pas de problème je vais
peut-être vous poser quelques questions
quelques coureurs mais ça va sans
gravité ça vous n'êtes pas contre dans
l'eau non pas les tours mais on ne veut
pas être traités comme comme par exemple
hier les thibault m si ça continue comme
ça l'est pour nous c'est triste mais
finit bien girard on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants bien entendu on va
revenir sur effectivement le déroulement
de ces perquisitions puis aussi la suite
des événements parmi les plus décidés à
arrêter la compétition qui selon lui n'a
plus d'intérêt puisqu'il figure à la
rubrique des faits divers et non plus à
la page des sports laurent jalabert et
son équipe
on sait rejoints par l'équipe banesto
qui ont toutes les deux abandonné
patrick fandio jocelyn l'air muzion ce
matin sur la ligne de départ albertville
comme si de rien était laurent jalabert
dédicace pour ses fans comme si de rien
n'était les vélos sont préparés mais le
directeur sportif des hans et exprime
déjà sa solidarité avec les tv m
si nous ne sont capables de le montrer
sur les rallyes terre nous
nous nous changerait un commerçant c'est
de laurent jalabert que viendra le coup
d'éclat au km 32 peu après le premier
arrêt des coureurs
le numéro un mondial décide d'abandonner
son équipe le suit mais on sait
n'arriveront pas sur les champs-elysées
dans ces conditions c'est plus le tour
moi je suis désolé on voulait vraiment
leur toute l'étape
vraiment c'est un signe de protestation
et c'est pas une protestation au moins
c'est être ridicule
et prouver que encore une fois on n'est
pas capable de précisions ma décision
j'en ai prises je suis tranquille et ma
conscience j'estime que sur ce tour j'ai
pris la tournure des événements et les
crs et je me mets donc voilà je crois
que je n'en mets gens peut-être y penser
comme ça mais c'est pas grave
direction l'hôtel pour cette dernière
journée sur le tour de france l'équipe
se préparait déjà à la perquisition que
la rumeur annonçait sans prendre parti
qui reliait tout de même une enquête de
la justice
la nouvelle goutte qui a fait déborder
le vase aujourd'hui celle annonce donc
de nouvelles perquisitions dans les
hôtels de plusieurs équipes à l'arrivée
à aix-les-bains ceci s'ajoutant aux
épisodes précédents
pascalou c'est bon laurent habib a
rarement une perquisition a été plus
annoncé les policiers lillois assisté de
collègues lyonnais sont arrivés à
l'hôtel de l'équipe on sait à peine plus
d'une heure après les coureurs
en fait je garde les clés je reste avec
monsieur en attendant qu'on fasse une
visite du camion il s'agit bien des
suites de l'affairé festina la semaine
dernière en garde à vue alex tu le
actuellement chez festina mes anciens de
ronde c'est aurait déclaré que l'équipe
espagnole pratiquer le même dopage
systématique que l'équipe française avec
le même financement par prélèvement sur
les primes de kwh quelques instants plus
tard l'équipe casino reçoit une visite
analogues
l'encadrement de l'équipe on est excédés
je veux dire on a vraiment l'impression
d'être des criminels nous en train là
ouais j'arrive à l'hôte allemand attende
il jouera pas là
vous attendiez
dispositif de céret ça vous fait penser
à quoi on peut penser à la guerre 39 40
ce tout ce que j'ai a déclaré gilles
bouvart actuelle coureurs de casino et
ancien de festina aurait lui aussi parlé
dopage devant le juge les lois patrick
keil d'où cette perquisition
et comme dans une partition bien apprise
les enquêteurs lillois sont au même
moment à challes-les-eaux demeure d'un
soir de la française des jeux
même principe emmanuel magnien lui aussi
ancien de festina aurait fait des
confidences aux magistrats de lille deux
de ses trois perquisitions sont encore
en cours à cette heure ci soit son père
sur place bonsoir la grande
préoccupation des corps ce sont les
conditions dans lesquelles s'effectue
perquisitions et interrogatoires ils se
poursuivent tous les deux ce soir et
dans quelles conditions
écoutez actuellement nous nous trouvons
ici au château de candie à chambéry où
se trouve l'équipe on sait et pouvez le
voir sur ces images la caméra va nous
quitter un instant le bus que vous voyez
au fond derrière les cars de crs qui
sont arrivés il ya quelques minutes en
renfort dans ce but se trouvent
actuellement les officiers de police
judiciaire du srpj de lille avec le
manager de l'équipe on sait et avec des
officiels de l'équipe on sait donc
actuellement la perquisition est
toujours en cours il ya quelques minutes
quand ces renforts de crs sont arrivés
ici pour protéger ce bus pour faire que
cette perquisition se déroule dans de
bonnes conditions
il ya eu on va dire des mouvements de
tension très important entre les
mécaniciens les soigneurs de l'équipe on
sait ils ont parlé de police dictatorial
des expressions excessive mais il ya eu
vraiment des moments de tension ici donc
perquisition toujours en cours ici à
l'intérieur de l'hôtel derrière moi
laurent jalabert est actuellement en
train d'être interrogés voilà les seules
informations nous avons pour le moment
donc dans quelles conditions laurent
jalabert est interrogé dans quelles
conditions se passe la perquisition dans
le bus pas d'information mais pour le
moment ça se déroule dans un calme
relatif
l'otan perd une autre question tout de
même il n'ya pas que l'équipe compte
c'est qui est perquisitionné ce soir
d'après nos informations non tout à fait
actuellement il ya deux autres
perquisitions encore une perquisition à
l'hôtel novotel de chambéry c'est à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici où se
trouve l'équipe casino vous l'avez vu
le reportage de pascal douce est bon il
ya quelques instants la perquisition est
toujours en cours dans cet hôtel au
siège de l'équipe casino dans quelles
conditions je ne sais pas à vingt
kilomètres d'ici à l'hôtellerie des
comptes de challes à challes une autre
perquisition est en cours à challes
c'est le siège de l'équipe de la
française des jeux directeur sportif
marc madiot
donc pour le moment d'après nos
informations trois perquisitions en
cours et des auditions de coureurs de
directeur sportif et sûrement de
médecins ici non seulement le relais
jalabert a été interrogée mais aussi le
médecin de l'équipe on sait merci claude
vous restez avec nous bien entendu pour
d'autres informations
retour sur cet événement d'hier soir là
perquisitions et l'interrogatoire de
plusieurs coureurs et responsable de
l'équipe hollandaise tvn soupçonné comme
l'équipe festina de dopage donc les
coureurs ont protesté contre les
conditions leur interrogatoire
même si de son côté la justice indique
aucune brutalité n'a été exercée à
l'encontre des champions interrogé
pascal nous c'est bon et rémy posséder
your hands la eleven s'était fait
discret jusqu'à présent mais ce matin le
sprinter des tv m a choisi de parler
parler de colère et de tristesse
j'allais prendre ma douche mais les
policiers ne m'en n'ont même pas laissé
le temps pas plus qu'eux d'aller au
massage si important pour nous beaucoup
d'entre nous ont pleuré cette nuit les
coureurs ne sont sortis qu'à minuit de
l'hôpital d'albertville
les policiers de reims réclamaient des
analyses d'uriné de sang et de cheveux
ces examens capillaires sont les seuls à
pouvoir révéler la présence de p ô dans
l'organisme chez pvm
des sourires étaient de rigueur comme
toujours depuis le début de la faire
mais le coeur n'y était plus
les cyclistes de l'équipe hollandaise ne
parle pas de mauvais traitements au
cours des auditions mais il reproche aux
policiers de ne pas avoir pris en compte
les exigences et les contraintes
horaires de leur sport et ce matin à
albertville le public semblait leur
donner raison
malgré les soupçons de dopage on a
entendu tout à l'heure le directeur du
tour jean-marie leblanc demandé que les
interrogatoires et perquisitions que ce
soir se passe dans les meilleures
conditions possibles liens par avance le
procureur de lille en charge du dossier
de l'affairé festina mais a répondu il
entend bien lui que les auditions aient
lieu ce soir
quatre coureurs au moins devraient être
interrogés en écoute même si et les
actes d'instruction perturbe le tour il
fallait absolument que seat élus que ces
auditions un lieu que ces perquisitions
ait lieu parce que comme je vous disais
d'un de vos confrères tout à l'heure il
ya quand même quelqu'un qui est encore à
la maison d'arrêt il s'agit du docteur
ricard 1 d une des justifications de son
maintien en détention c'est d'éviter des
pressions sur les témoins me bien
évident qu'on doit entendre dans les
meilleurs délais ces témoins deux fois
sans pouvoir statuer sur une éventuelle
demande nicole bertrand y aura d'autres
d'autres actes est un élément nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que il y à un deuxième
magistrat instructeur qui en charge du
dossier à la demande de monsieur patrick
keil de façon à ce qu'il continue telle
information qui n'est pas ce qu'on
déplore de temps en temps j'allais dire
un petit creux dans l'information pour
man l'évocation des prix
voilà donc pour les faits du jour en
direct avec nous donc de genève
richard virenque qui sorte de son
mutisme qu'il observe depuis 11 jours
depuis son départ forcé du tour de
france assisté de son avocat maître
collard et servira un bonsoir bonsoir
bien richard vient avec une première
question toute simple que pensez vous de
ce qui se passe ce soir de ce que vous
venez de voir ben c'est triste cette
presse et 13 pour le tour de france est
très sport le vent général est ce qu'on
a vécu il ya dix jours personne s'en est
trop soucié et bien maintenant ça s'est
étendu un peu plus loin donc le chapeau
ils se déplacent vous aviez parlé de vos
conditions de garde à vue vous ne vous
êtes pas beaucoup exprimé là dessus
c'est ce que dénoncent les coureurs
quels ont été les veaux qu'est ce qui
choque les coureurs dans dans les
interrogatoires que vous subissez je
crois que les coureurs n'ont rien eu de
comparable avec ce que nous on a pu
avoir effectué 24 qu'on est resté 24
heures en garde à vue c'est 7 8 heures
d'interrogatoire ensuite déshabillé
fouillé
et dans un trou dans une cellule avec
une lumière que vous empêche de dormir
et c'est ces conditions aucun courant en
pelotant jusqu'à présent les a subi et
personne ne s'en est soucié en tout cas
et aujourd'hui on commence à faire
beaucoup de bruit parce qu'il ya des
coureurs qui se sont couchés à minuit
mais nous pour l'instant on nous a sorti
du tour et on nous a mis au trou et on
nous a ridiculisés au plus bas donc le
mal il a été fait et le public s'en est
rendu compte en tout cas et c'est bien
pour ça qu'ils étaient tous là derrière
en train de me demander de revenir mais
le problème on nous a jetés dehors
maître collard vous êtes à côté de
richard virenque vous mettez en cause
les conditions de la garde à vue doit
être notre client la garde à vue s'est
déroulée d'une façon tout à fait
conforme à la loi mais il se trouve que
la loi est scandaleuse le grand public
ignore et peut-être la prendre at il par
cette affaire qu'un simple témoin ce qui
était le cas de richard peut être placé
en garde à vue
ce qu'ils ignorent également c'est que
les conditions de la garde à vue sont
très dures et ce que richard virenque
eux n'a pas dit mais qui m'autorise à
dire c'est que pendant la garde à vue on
va jusqu'à des mines et dénudé le gardé
à vue et à lui faire une fouille anale
pour voir s'ils ne cachent pas dans
l'anus je ne sais quoi c'est pas illégal
c'est dans le cadre de cette loi qui
scandalise tout le monde il faudrait
quand même que on arrive rapidement à
réformer ce système pour que l'on ne
confonde pas le citoyen ordinaire qui a
une affaire quelconque qui doit
s'expliquer qui était moins avec un avec
le délinquant chevronné qui au demeurant
entre nous se moque pas mal de la
période de garde à vue et c'est vrai que
tous les coureurs qui ont été enfermés
dans cette garde à vue ont été
profondément choqué par les conditions
de la garde à vue
et puis dans les quelque chose qu'on
peut ajouter c'est que le tact
malheureusement on peut pas leur donner
au nom de la loi alors richard vient que
revenons à votre affaire vous avez
toujours nié vous persistez à nier que
vous avez été dopés ou bien est-ce que
vous avez changé d'avis vos coéquipiers
certains de vos coéquipiers ont avoué
votre directeur sportif aussi ainsi que
le médecin n'y a que vous qui
je n'ai jamais été dopés enfin jusqu'à
ce soir à ma connaissance qu'on peut
vous étiez en face de moi quand on m'a
interrogé pendant huit heures donc
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez savoir ce que
j'ai pu raconter la cardio nerfs oui
mais moi je vous dis que j'ai parlé j'ai
parlé pendant huit à neuf heures et
simon relâché c'est qu'ils avaient pas
mal de raisons et de daim 10 sur pas mal
de choses
moi je suis professionnel et je fais mon
métier le mieux possible si je fais
confiance à des personnes notamment au
médecin ou à d'autres personnes c'est
pas de mon ressort
ça va ça veut dire que vous avez pu être
dopée à votre insu sans le savoir mais
dopé à 15 ans au mois jusqu'à présent
jamais été pris positif eu un
automobiliste il se fait arrêter pour un
contrôle d'andal côté s'il va souffler
dans le ballon le ballon on va dire
qu'il n'a rien vu vous allez quand même
lui met un retrait de permis
- pour ma part j'ai toujours été un
contrôle ou alors il faut changer les
règlements cci qui doit changer tout ça
donc je crois que c'est ministère des
sports plus et y qui doit tout revoir
faire une grande table ronde parce que
le problème il est là le problème il
n'est pas au niveau des coureurs est ce
que ce problème il faut tout revoir
est ce que ça veut dire richard virenque
que les tests sanguins que vous avez pu
subir ou encore le test des cheveux sont
ou seront négatives pour ce qui vous
concerne
j'en sais rien tout ce que je sais c'est
qu'on m'a coupé les cheveux on m'a fait
il dirait encore un peu plus
d'immunisation ont pris du sens mais
c'était à mon volonté j'aurais pu
refuser
oui donc moi j'ai un amour au prochain
ils ont fait ça et je crois que quelques
ennuis on est tous traités les coureurs
d'un même façon on fera un jugement et
après on verra le chapeau si les saouler
festina ou aussi un problème en général
fahri lien il y a tout de même
l'aveu de votre directeur sportif l'aveu
du médecin l'aveu du soigneur et puis
vous tout seul au milieu de mouiller au
milieu de tout ça un désaveu chacun dit
ce qu'il veut mais en tout cas
ce serait bien que la police faire
parler les 22 directeur sportif qu'il
est maître 48 heures en garde à vue et
je crois que même ce qu'ils ont en main
pas fait ils avoueront donc si tout le
monde tout le peloton est traitée pareil
on pourra faire des conclusions
donc est-ce que vous pensez que j'ai un
problème global du dopage dans le sport
cycliste qui met dans l'eau ce la santé
des champions doit avoir votre vie pour
certains traitements
écoutez moi ce que je fais je fais un
métier je crois le plus fabuleux pour
moi je fais du sport je suis rêver les
gens et pour rien au monde ce que je
fais je regrette bien au contraire
donc le problème il est aujourd'hui ce
que les médias se mettre là-dedans et
essaye de faire des règles la police
découvre des choses mais jusqu'à présent
les règles étaient comme ça tout le
peloton international ce météo règles de
l'uci est donc maintenant il ya des
problèmes c'est qu'il ya des substances
qui sont peut-être indécelable donc
c'est surtout le problème maintenant des
médecins ou des
je sais pas mais de ceux qui mettent les
règles qui devraient instaurer des
nouvelles règles instaurées des choses
mais nous sportif qu'est ce qu'on y peut
là dedans on se
vous pouvez toujours refusé un certain
nombre de traitements qui vous semble un
petit peu partie remise et d'un majeur
écoutez écoutez je suis un professionnel
et je moi je
je travaille le au maximum qui
m'entraîne et je fais énormément de
sacrifices au niveau de la nourriture
comme quand il ya un médecin dans
l'équipe ça fait sept ans que je
travaille avec et benjamines ont toute
ma confiance pour travailler avec jeu
fait d'énormes sacrifices et là vous
voulez me demander de refuser des choses
on se plie à des règles de l'ue c'est
donc je vous demande simplement si vous
avez pu être trompés maître collard est
ce que presque richard virenque peut
finalement plaidé comme dans une autre
affaire coupable cette fois ci mais pas
responsables non je crois je crois qu'il
peut d'abord il n'a pas appelé des
puisqu'il faut quand même le rappeler
à ce jour il est témoin et il a adressé
hier au juge d'instruction une lettre
par laquelle ils demandent à se
constituer partie civile bon donc il
n'est pas aujourd'hui accusé je crois
qu'il faut bien le rappeler
les coureurs du tour de france ne sont
pas aujourd'hui accusée par la justice
ils sont entendus comme témoins alors
qu'elle va être en fin de compte la
position générale de richard virenque et
des autres coureurs
c'est de dire que s'il ya eu quelque
part une preuve de dopage
elle s'est effectuée pour ceux qui n'ont
jamais demandé à être dopée à leur insu
comme sont pas des abrutis
ils savent très bien qu'ils aient un
système qui est en place qui a pu ne pas
les atteindre du fait de leur volonté
mais qui est profondément critiquable et
qu'il faut arriver un jour ou l'autre à
dénoncer parce qu en vinyle qu'est ce
qu'on veut on veut que la bataille de
plus en plus vite et pour qu'elle ait de
plus en plus qu'est ce qu'on fait on la
fouettent alors jeté à preuve du
contraire c'est pas la bête qu'on doit
punir sans lecteur et je crois qu'il
serait quand même un peu
un peu utile que à l'heure actuelle en
remettent les choses en place et l'on
cherche à sauver malgré tout l'homme du
sport et l'âme de l'effort dax que tous
les coureurs ne sont pas d'aider des
gens qui agissent sous l'effet sous
l'effet des drogues
richard virenque com comment voyez vous
l'avenir de ce tour de france est ce que
vous pensez finalement qu'on aurait dû
l'arrêter lorsque votre équipe et vous
même avait été expulsé d'une certaine
façon
ou bien est ce qu'on doit l'arrêter ce
soir c'est trop faut s'arrêter là au
jour d'aujourd'hui je sais pas quoi
penser de tout ça mais en tout cas je
crois que le jour où on s'est fait
sortir dehors je pensais que j'espérais
que les coureurs prennent ça pour tous
et soit solidaire avec avec nous qu'on
nous met dehors nous avoir laissé tomber
une certaine façon oui non je crois que
c'était un contre la montre et c'était
c'est difficile de mobiliser tout le
monde à ce moment là mais je crois que
le vent leur est tombée dessus une
semaine après voilà où on en est alors
sur le tour de france revient la
question vous pensez qu'il faut
s'arrêter là ré introduire de nouvelles
règles iront fait une amie si on repart
à zéro sous d'autres conditions
je crois que le tournoi continue et
après le tour il faudra que les grandes
instances
je crois que les politiques et tout le
monde se réunit autour d'une table et
discutent d'accord le sport en général
et faire un maximum pour pour les
contrôles pour tout ça mais je
un dernier mot à dire je remercie
énormément tous les gens qui m'ont
soutenu et tous ceux qui l'ont soutenu
aussi l'équipe et j'espère leur donner
beaucoup de choses
en tout cas richard jour d'aujourd'hui
je savais que c'était difficile de
gagner le tour mais je sais que demain
jour je gagnerai richa lorsque vous
voyez justement un italien comme marco
pantani en tête d'un tour de france
c'est à dire un grimpeur comme vous vous
n'avez pas encore plus de regrets de ne
plus y être c'est sûr ça donne des idées
mais bon quand se fait mettre dehors
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
qu'est ce que rapporte richard même si
nous avons des questions parfois assez
dur et c'est notre métier nous sommes
enfin je suis pour ma part un amateur de
cyclisme
et puis cette année je suis un peu
choqué comme des millions de passionnés
je ne sais pas trop quoi penser qu est
ce que vous avez à me dire pour me
rassurer sur sur votre sport sur votre
métier
moi tout ce que j'ai à vous dire c'est
que nous on fait un maximum pour pour
donner le meilleur de nous mêmes et que
dans la course on fait des belles étapes
on est professionnel jusqu'à 100% donc
le vélo cc il faut pas oublier qu'on
donne beaucoup de nous et et on passait
par 3500 km dans l'année ont fait
énormément de sacrifices de course et
ont fait vibrer des gens et il ya des
lois qui existent donc on se plie à tout
ça donc nous là dedans on suit les
règles et on richard houis vous n'êtes
pas les tricheurs mais tricheurs pour
vous les conçoit des tricheurs on ose la
question surtout en toute simplicité
ben non moi je pense pas être très cher
au contraire quand je me regarde dans
une glace ne baisse pas la tête quand je
regarde une personne je la regarde
toujours en face et pour moi je suis pas
un tricheur
et qu'on veut mettre un tour de france à
ma peau et on verra si je suis dopé ou
pas merci richard virenque merci maître
collard merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct ce soir merci à vous les
événements d'aujourd'hui vous en doutez
n'ont pas laissé indifférent le public
très présent toujours sur les étapes de
montagne des spectateurs choqués par les
événements en cours mais aussi des
coureurs choqué par les événements de la
journée notamment celui qui est en tête
de la course
marco pantani l'italien ils peuvent le
tour n'est pas un jeu on risque notre
vie dans le des 110 tapas tanto face à
montanes temps fatigué jusqu'à mon la
vitrine des chaises et on a le cyclisme
est un sport qui demande des sacrifices
qu'il y ait des sacrifices il est
inadmissible que la police a pris dans
ma chambre
on cherchait de la vitamine c la
vitamine attire ou qu'elle mène en
prison ils pourront surprendre si ce que
j'ai dans ma valise est autorisé ou non
nés là-bas lydia et kane giusto c'est
aussi un juge dont les coureurs un
champion qui on est soit traité comme un
assassin ring'n'roll pas ce qu'on
nommait con mais on assassine et non
comme est
la tv publique et aujourd'hui ils sont
restés jusqu'à 2 heures du matin on aura
les sans manger
pour moi c'est une violation des droits
de l'homme rami
des louanges une en violation à la
personne
voilà donc pour cet entretien de jean
paul ollivier avec marco pantani le
maillot jaune du tour de france je vous
disais à l'instant les événements
d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas laissé
indifférents les milliers de spectateurs
qui se pressent toujours sur les bords
de la route du tour de france notamment
dans les étapes de montagne reportage de
nathalie moisan emmanuel bec silence
pesant sur la ligne d'arrivée alors où
les coureurs on régule à franchir aucune
effervescence dans la tribune des
commentateurs les gradins vides des
personnalités lassés d'attendre les
caméras du direct sans leur cadreur
partis se mettre à l'ombre et partout au
bord de la route
ce public patients solidaire des
coureurs moi je crois qu'il serait peu
raison c'est normal c'est leur métier se
défend moore leur façon correcte et là
les partis sauf incorrect annulé festina
ne pas nous aimer bf c'est normal c'est
pas normal pardon des oraisons s'est
manifesté il ya d'autres sports où
certains sportifs se dote se drogue par
exemple
la coupe du monde en football il ya
peut-être aussi des drogues qui passe à
ce moment là aussi pourquoi spécialement
les coureurs sont attaqués en ce moment
chacun s'informe comme il peut de la
course devant les écrans de télévision
la tristesse domine réduit éclaté après
le tour quoi que le tour se passe se
passe normalement
parce que c'est quand même un spectacle
c'est quelque chose qu'on attend nous
toute une année et il ya qui valent à
jour c'est la fête est gâchée quoi le
tour de france que c'est quelque chose
de formidable c'est tout le monde vivait
ça c'était on avait deux idoles dans des
courses et nous idole tous d'un seul
coup cac ce que ça alors on va savoir
pourquoi il faudrait aussi que on sache
la vérité quelque chose les ans un
cycliste qui ont suivi l'étape en
voiture sont évidemment solidaires des
coureurs une solidarité teintée
d'amertume sur battue je suis très
triste
c'est pas j'ai l'impression que
on en veut aux coureurs on en veut au
tour de france surtout et c'est
difficile d'avoir une réaction
je ne comprends pas vers les coureurs
qui ont été contrôlés par la police
je ne sais pas d'où vient les ordres
mais ils ont été contents de contrôler
comme de véritables criminels
il y en a même certains qui en qui on
dit que c'est tout juste sur les papas
sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est vrai
mais si si c'est vrai c'est inadmissible
pourquoi maintenant pendant le tour de
france pourquoi le cyclisme est il
particulièrement visés des questions que
se posent tous les observateurs du tour
tous ceux qui craignent que le tour de
france se soit arrêtée ce soir à aix les
bains
on a un mot avec le plus de recul
possible puisque vous vous suivez
l'événement qu'est les sentiments du
public sur le tour par rapport aux
événements et quel est votre sentiment à
vous vous êtes un des spectateurs
finalement oui c'est un des premiers
spectateurs on est souvent sur le bord
de la route on est juste derrière le
peloton en un mot il s'est passé une
chose très importante aujourd'hui à deux
niveaux et u2 fissure aujourd'hui
premières fissures dans la solidarité du
peloton parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui autour de bjarne riis qui
pourtant a porté la bonne parole
tous les coureurs n'avaient pas la même
la même opinion la preuve c'est que
jalabert par exemple a dit moi on ne me
suis pas et je préfère partir de la
course
première grosse fissure donc un manque
de solidarité de la part des coureurs
même s'ils ont quand même décidé d'aller
au bout d'allée avec ce les bains et de
et de terminer le tour de france parce
que ça ils veulent absolument le
terminer et puis du côté du public pour
la première fois il des coureurs se sont
fait conspuer la presse de temps en
temps ça fait conspuer les organisateurs
de temps en temps se sont fait huer
mais là pour la première fois le public
qui était
mécontent qui comprenait pas tellement
ce qui se passait a crié un peu sur les
coureurs
alors ça c'est très important parce que
le tour de france qui est l'un des
sports les plus populaires au monde
c'est vrai qu'on avec une grande coupe
du monde mais là le tour c'est tous les
ans bien il ya 15 millions de
spectateurs sur le bord des routes ou
les ans c'est une histoire d'amour est
là dans l'histoire d'amour et pour la
première fois on est vraiment à l'heure
de vérité c'est vrai qu'il faut de la
vérité en amour et c'est vrai qu'il
faudra aller jusqu'au bout tout le monde
le dit même les coureurs le disent
faut vraiment que les choses soient
claires les coureurs veulent de grands
et deux très importants contrôle mais
tout dépend de la manière et surtout du
côté du public là maintenant on comprend
moins bien qu'avant il y aura peut-être
avant et après cette étape d'aujourd'hui
merci gérard deux informations trois
informations encore à propos du tour de
france le coureur français luc leblanc
vient d'un dit luc leblanc pardon bien
indiqué qu'il ne repartirait pas demain
matin
et puis une déclaration dans le journal
le monde du président de la fédération
française de cyclisme daniel balle et
qui estime que les coureurs ne peuvent
pas être traités comme des voyous mais
il dit je ne connaît pas encore
l'ampleur de la maladie la proportion
des cordes op mais je crois qu'elle elle
est très importante aujourd'hui il faut
que l'accès soit crevé il est nécessaire
d'aller au bout il faut tout savoir et
puis dernière chose jean claude killy
qui est le président de la société du
tour de france qui déclarait ce matin
dans un article du journal l'équipe
on ne détruit pas un mythe les autres
titres de l'actualité d'abord deux
milliards sept d'économies pour limiter
le déficit de la sécurité sociale la
ministre martine aubry a annoncé
aujourd'hui le détail des mesures qui
touchent principalement les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et certains spécialistes
comme les radiologues martine aubry a
aussi assuré que les mesures d'économies
ne toucheront pas les assurés sociaux
laurent bailly eric de lannion pour les
deux ministres en charge de la sécurité
sociale martine aubry et bernard
kouchner une obsession commune ramener
le déficit de la branche maladie autour
de 5 milliards de francs cette année
mais comme les dépenses de santé
explosent le 7% depuis janvier il faut
distille réaliser 2 milliards 700
millions de francs d'économies
d'abord en rognant sur les profits de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
avec la baisse du prix de certains
médicaments les laboratoires verront
leurs revenus baisser de près de 2
milliards de francs sur un chiffre
d'affaires il est vrai soixante cinq
fois supérieure
mais ce sont surtout les radiologues qui
seront touchés avec 450 millions prend
de manque à gagner
comme leurs revenus ont augmenté de 10%
cette année le gouvernement va en effet
abaissé les tarifs de trait et demi pour
cent sur certains actes courants c'est
une mesure majeure drastiques
elle n'est que temporaire elle doit nous
permettre de faire rentrer dans les
caisses si je puis dire
les 450 millions de dérapage inexpliqué
depuis le début de l'année la mesure qui
a été annoncée ce matin est une mesure
brutale conjoncturelle
inacceptables parce qu'elle change les
règles du jeu pour une seule catégorie
de médecins insupportable pour la
profession puisque elle diminue de 30 %
le revenu des médecins
enfin les biologistes dentiste
prothésiste entre autres sont aux aussi
mis à contribution à hauteur de 550
millions de francs dans ces professions
les hausses de tarifs qui devait
intervenir ces jours ci sont repoussé de
plusieurs mois
le conseil constitutionnel vient à
l'instant de censurer cet article de la
loi de martine aubry sur contre les
exclusions touchant notamment les
saisies immobilières et l'obligation
d'hébergement des personnes expulsées
s'agissant de la taxe sur les logements
vacants qui était l'élément principal du
dépôt de la motion des députés de
l'opposition et bien le conseil a
précisé qu'un logement meublé en vue de
son occupation et comme tel assujettis à
la taxe d'habitation ne saurait être
regardé comme vacants l'accord sur les
35 heures entre les syndicats
minoritaires de la métallurgie et la
fédération industrielle de ce secteur
qui ne compte pas moins de 2 millions de
salariés et rejeté par les syndicats
majoritaires cgt et cfdt qui estime que
la loi
finalement est tournée c'est aussi
l'avis de la ministre de l'emploi et de
la solidarité
martine aubry sébastien guibert josé
boulesteix
pour denis gautier sauvagnac cette
signature vos victoires
le vice président de l'union patronale
des industries métallurgiques et
minières
lui-même a finalement convaincu trois
syndicats sur cinq de parapher l'accord
sur les 35 heures cet accord respecte la
loi
il respecte les personnes est évidemment
si vous le permettez pour un responsable
de la métallurgie
il respecte les entreprises et l'emploi
c'est au nom de la compétitivité que le
patronat obtenu plus de flexibilité des
horaires de travail et surtout
l'augmentation du nombre maximum
d'heures supplémentaires qu'un salarié
pourra effectuer chaque année 180 au
lieu de 94
petit calcul aujourd'hui un salarié de
ce secteur avec 39 heures hebdomadaires
et 94 heures supplémentaires parents
travaillent au maximum en moyenne
quarante et une heure par semaine avec
l'accord 35 heures légales 180 heures
supplémentaires la moyenne descend à
peine à 38 heures par semaine maximum
du coup pas de création d'emplois près
inacceptable pour la cgt la cfdt la
réduction du temps de travail
elle n'a de sens que si elle se traduit
par plus d'emplois et par moins de
travail c'est la condition pour faire
reculer le chômage
il s'agit d' un mardi noir
un mardi noir pour la réduction du temps
de travail le mardi noir pour l'emploi
les signataires fo cgc et cftc parlent
eux de cadre national clair pour les
négociations en entreprise
martine aubry de son côté est bien plus
sévère c'est une innovation dans le
droit français d'avoir une convention
collective qui est encore en quelque
sorte un accord vie actuelle un espèce
de non-accord sur lesquelles les
partenaires se mettent d'accord
voilà alors si ça fait plaisir à
lui-même bah c'est déjà bien
ça n'aura aucun effet sur les salariés
puisque c'est pas applicable pas
applicable avant le 1er janvier 2000 ce
sont les termes de l'accord un texte que
martine aubry juge sans valeur comparé
aux accords signés actuellement dans les
entreprises
l'accident de l'autoroute a7 hier près
de montélimar qui a fait je vous le
rappelle cette mort et sept blessés
graves
après le chauffeur du poids lourd celui
du carol landais qui a violemment
percuté deux autres autocars a été mise
en examen
accusé de ne pas avoir maîtrisé la
vitesse de son véhicule qui roulait trop
vite virginie fichet olivier chatin
quatre heures durant le jeu
d'instruction a entendu les deux
chauffeurs avant de les remettre en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire
tout comme le conducteur du bus hollande
et que l'on voit ici le chauffeur du
poids lourd qui s'était endormi au
volant a lui aussi été mis en examen
pour homicides et blessures
involontaires au bout de 24 heures il ne
faut pas tirer de conclusions trop
hâtives
comme je voulais dit le juge
d'instruction déterminera quelle est la
responsabilité claque de l'un et de
l'autre
pour ma part il m'apparut inopportun et
peut-être aussi inégal des cartes et a
priori sa responsabilité la nuit du
drame le poids lourd se couche sur
l'autoroute et provoque un bouchon
une demi-heure plus tard le chauffeur du
bus hollandais sera le seul à ne pas
s'arrêter
le dispositif de signalisation du
ralentissement semblait pourtant bien en
place les enquêteurs n'ont relevé aucune
anomalie
quand je suis arrivé ça vire 35 40
minutes après l'accident la synergie on
était en place c'est-à-dire les
patrouilleurs
qui recule en fonction de la longueur du
bouchon tout était en place d une heure
huit la société d'autoroute avait
connaissance du premier accident son
dispositif de protection étaient en
place à peine 8 minutes plus tard les
relevés informatiques la teste
cette nuit-là deux patrouilleurs comme
ceux-ci baliser les lieux sur chaque
type d'accident les procédures
d'intervention sont très précise toutes
sont répertoriés rien n'est laissé au
hasard
il se met mini au minimum à 300 mètres
en amont de l'événement que son accident
ou un bouchon afin de signaler aux
usagers qui arrive
l'imminence de l'événement le jour ces
signaux lumineux peuvent être visibles à
près d'un kilomètre
la nuit leur portée presque doublé
pourtant le chauffeur hollande est lui
ne les a pas vus
aujourd'hui il dit ne s'être rendu
compte de la situation qu'au moment du
choc
libération sous caution et surveillance
policière d'un hooligans allemands
soupçonnés dans l'agression du crs de
lens qui peine à incarcérer son big and
dans le nord de la france à lille pour
l'instant le juge estime qu'il manque
d'éléments à charge contre sur lui
gagnent un second reagan reste écroué à
la prison de loos libre scandale dans un
établissement psychiatrique de mirecourt
dans les vosges près d'epinal des
personnels infirmiers sont accusés de
violences sur les pensionnaires de
l'établissement reste in both pas très
chouette
le centre hospitalier ravenel est sous
le choc
sous le choc des révélations d'une aide
soignante témoin d'agissements scandale
de certains de ses collègues dans cette
unité de long séjour du pavillon vini
trois derrière ses barreaux certains
malades étaient injurié maltraités roué
de coups le graves accusations
confirmées par des infirmières qui ont
permis de mettre au jour une deuxième
affaire qui date de 1995 l'un des aides
soignants a rappelé qu'à l'époque il
avait révélé un supérieur hiérarchique
des faits qui seraient susceptibles
d'être des coûts sur un malade qui est
décédé quelques jours après ces coups
avaient été portés avec une chaise
métallique sur la tête du malade
parallèlement à l'action judiciaire une
enquête administrative est en cours pour
tenter de comprendre comment ces faits
ont pu se produire et perdurer et
effectivement certainement une main du
silence qui a existé qui est subsiste
encore un peu partiellement
actuellement c'est ce qui rend la lente
est d'autant plus difficile une enquête
délicate en raison même de l'univers
psychiatrique dénoncé par l'avocat des
infirmiers mise en cause mes clients
étaient dans un service qui était le
service est plus dur en milieu
psychiatrique
il travaille à 4 pour 45 malades
gravement malade et c'est peu à qui on
vient dire à un moment vous avez perdu
votre calme ce matin un des infirmiers a
été mise en examen pour violences
volontaires
sur personnes particulièrement
vulnérables et placé en détention
un autre infirmier est toujours en garde
à vue il devrait faire l'objet de
poursuites pour coups et blessures ayant
entraîné la mort sans intention de la
donner d'un ministre de l'environnement
dominique voynet et celui de
l'agriculture louis le pensec ont fait
savoir aux agriculteurs des quatre
départements bretons qu'ils allaient
devoir construire des stations
d'épuration afin de limiter la pollution
agricole alarmante dans ces départements
bretons cela concerne essentiellement
les éleveurs de porcs qui protestent car
les cours actuels sont au plus bas et
ses installations coûtent cher reportage
payer sioux gabriel kane la bretagne une
nouvelle fois dans le collimateur la
bretagne ou plutôt ses cochons depuis
longtemps jugés responsables de la
pollution de l'eau dominique voynet
louis le pensec viennent donc de mettre
au point une circulaire qui rend
obligatoire le traitement du lisier
notamment par la limitation de
l'épandage ou l'installation de
véritables stations d'épuration dans les
élevages les plus importants cette
circulaire les préfets des quatre
départements bretons ont reçu en avant
première ce qui n'a rien d'un hasard
toute la bretagne classée zone
vulnérable il ya soixante dix sept
cantons en france qui sont en deuil
c'est à dire en zone d'excédent
structurel qui produisent donc trop
d'azov et en bretagne en à 71 donc c'est
énorme
et dans ces zones et via la directive va
être appliqué une directive qui prévoit
donc entre autres la construction
d'unités de traitement pour les
exploitations de plus de 180 port jean a
quant lui a déjà pris les devants
il ya quatre ans il a fait construire
pour son élevage de 100 truies
cette mini station d'épuration capable
de traiter à elles seules les eaux usées
d'une petite ville mais un
investissement qui a un coût 2 millions
de francs pas facile à rentabiliser
c'est un investissement quand même qui
représente un coût de l'ordre de 40
centimes du kilo voire plus dans le
contexte actuel c'est sûr que c'est une
charge difficile à supporter
dans la mesure où toutes les tous nos
concurrents aient toutes les régions
d'europe n'ont pas les mêmes contraintes
quelle région par exemple par exemple
l'espagne car la circulaire tombe mal le
port est à 6 francs 50 le kilo alors
qu'il faudrait cette nuit francs pour
atteindre le seuil de rentabilité certes
des aides sont prévues notamment pour
les exploitations les plus modestes mais
la protestation des agriculteurs
risquent de s'amplifier dans les jours à
venir
une bombe datant de la seconde guerre
mondiale découverte sur un chantier des
proches de la centrale nucléaire de
chinon en indre-et-loire l'engin d'un
mètre de long pesant 200 kg a pu être
désamorcée par les services de déminage
sans assumer élections à refaire à
toulon où la socialiste d'être casanova
qui avait battu au mois de mai dernier
de 33 voix
sandrine le chevalier a vu son élection
invalidée par le conseil constitutionnel
et cela à cause d'une émission de la
station de télévision canal+ diffusé le
jour même du second tour à connotation
anti front national
sandrine chevalier qui remplace son mari
député maire invalidé compte bien se
représente
alban nicosie il ya une 46
sur le cours lafayette le marché de
toulon pas un scrutin qui ne voit les
candidats arpenter ses étals odette
casanova n'est plus député de la
première circonscription
l'information fait la une des quotidiens
et engendre déjà des réactions
passionnées super contente
bon bah si c'est normal c'est normal
si ça doit être fait je pense que ça
doit être fait c'est un peu dégueulasse
a en tout le monde à voter pour vaincre
on l a gagné à la gagner c'est usant
parfois le 3 mai dernier la socialiste
odette casanova s'imposer de 33 voix un
écart très réduit face à sandrine le
chevalier du front national n'est car
qui a incité le conseil constitutionnel
a annulé le scrutin en raison de la
diffusion d'une séquence télévisée le
jour même du vote
une décision dont l'épousé du maire de
toulon se félicite madame casanova a
gagné c'est vrai le 3 mai mais de
prendre 3 voir avec des irrégularités
qui ont été fréquentes et reconnu par le
conseil professionnel
odette casanova a annoncé qu'elle serait
à nouveau candidate pour l'union de la
gauche sa bonne foi n'étant pas mis en
cause je repars au combat candidate plus
que jamais pour montrer si j'osais cette
comparaison comme le dit aimé jacquet
pour le mondial la persévérance a zappé
ce qu'ils étendent le rpr et l'udf vont
chercher un candidat commun présenté
daniel colin ici à gauche n'avait pas pu
atteindre le deuxième tour
l'enjeu est de taille aux débats
nationaux s'ajoutent les problèmes
locaux et notamment la crise en cours à
l'arsenal suite de l' enquête
parlementaire sur les tribunaux de
commerce arnaud montebourg le rapporteur
de la commission a annoncé la
transmission à la justice de huit
dossiers sur lesquels plane un soupçon
de corruption ou de prise illégale
d'intérêts quatre de ses huit dossiers
concernent le sol tribunal de paris
l'actualité internationale l'étau se
resserre autour du président américain
bill clinton monica levinsky a reçu
l'assurance de pouvoir témoigner sans
être poursuivi pour un premier faux
témoignage sur sa relation sexuelle
présumée avec le président des états
unis à nouveau ray apparaît donc le
spectre d'une démission possible de bill
clinton washington philippe gazeau les
grandes chaînes de télévision et les
photographes ont renforcé leurs
quartiers d'été devant les bâtiments de
la cour fédérale
l'immunité accordée à monica lewinsky
renforce l'intérêt de la presse qui n'a
cependant jamais mis le scandale en
veilleuse les camions de transmissions
ici n'ont pas bougé depuis six mois
maintenant on se prépare à l'audition
d'une monica lewinsky sereine certaine
de ne plus être inquiété par la justice
américaine
une gratification pour sa coopération
totale
résultat en fait d'une discussion âpre
où chacun y trouve son intérêt
les deux parties en présence envisage un
accord quand elles sont certaines que
c'est leur intérêt
quand elles sont convaincues l'accord
rapporte davantage il ne coûte kenneth
starr le procureur a des pouvoirs
exorbitants syllabes somme monica qui
demande l immunité sans succès depuis
six mois c'est qu'il est peut être
pressé par le temps et qu'il entend
ferrer beaucoup plus gros poisson
mademoiselle lewinsky dit la rumeur
aurait mangé le morceau est révélé
qu'elle avait bel et bien eu une liaison
avec le président ce que l'on a toujours
nié à la maison blanche
il lui aurait même demandé de garder
tout cela secret c'est peut être là
l'obstruction à la justice
la majorité de l'opinion publique trouve
maintenant que tout cela a trop duré
je pense qu'on est fatigué tout petit
soir ce que je voudrais c'est qu'on le
laisse tranquille et qu'on laisse
l'amérique avancé
si on peux pas le croire dans la sphère
peut-on le croire dont les autres
aspects de son activité
on attend de savoir maintenant quel sera
le système de défense de bill clinton
un président qui peut difficilement
faire marche arrière et admettre en
public qu'il a menti après la coupe du
monde de football retour au championnat
de france le psg le paris saint germain
se renforce pour la saison prochaine
le nigérian okocha la révélation du
mondial quitte la turquie pour venir
jouer en france à paris montant estimé
des transferts plus de 100 millions de
francs estelle bertrand josé boulesteix
pendant le mondial le nigérian jay jay
okocha a fait des étincelles
sa technique son coup d'oeil à sa
vivacité ont séduit le psg
paris n'a pas lésiné sur les moyens 102
millions de francs
voilà le prix qu'a payé charles biétry
pour débaucher okocha du club turc de
fenerbahçe le nigérian a signé pour
quatre ans et rejoindra sa nouvelle
équipe dès demain l'arrivée d'un tel
talent dans un groupe c'est toujours
positif
un joueur comme ça de cette qualité dans
son effectif puisque de pouvoir
travailler avec ces joueurs qui ont du
talent c'est toujours plus agréable et
ça en plus ça donne des moyens en groupe
une équipe d'abord d'autres possibilités
une vedette va peut-être en chasser une
autre
marco simone et n'arrive pas à trouver
un terrain d'entente avec charles biétry
sur les conditions de son renouvellement
de contrat en attendant l'italien était
pourtant à l'entraînement cet après midi
dans une équipe de vedettes valent
toujours mieux qu'une et suis dans
l'attenté des diamants de ne plus de
solution je dirais rapid poste puisque
le championnat approche et qu' il
faudrait savoir et bien sûr avec le tout
l'intérêt que j'ai pour marcos monnaies
sur place portif joueur de sa qualité
mais aussi sa seule minute ça serait
mieux qu'il soit anr effectivement c'est
sûr okocha ici mené dans la même équipe
ça fait rêver un entraîneur et courir
les supporteurs
retour sur le tour de france cycliste
clos de son père où en est on des
différentes perquisitions et
interrogatoires qui ont lieu depuis un
peu plus d'une heure maintenant écouter
au château candy à chambéry où se trouve
actuellement à l'équipe
on sait où nous nous trouvons
actuellement la perquisition est
toujours en cours dans le bus qui se
trouve derrière moi les inspecteurs sont
restés pendant une dizaine de minutes
avec pablo anton le manager de l'équipe
manu n 5 le directeur sportif
ils se trouvent actuellement dans le
deuxième but ce que vous pouvez
apercevoir au fond où la perquisition
continue donc dans l'hôtel qui se trouve
derrière moi on a discuté il ya quelques
minutes avec pablo anton le manager de
l'équipe et pablo stoll nous a dit qu'à
l'intérieur de l'anc de l'hôtel se
trouvait actuellement interrogé nicolas
terra dos le médecin de l'équipe et
laurent jalabert
voilà pour l'équipe on sait un châle à
une vingtaine de kilomètres d'ici où se
trouve l'équipe de la française des jeux
la perquisition est terminée et à
l'hôtel novotel à quelques centaines de
mètres d'ici où se trouve l'équipe
casino
la perquisition est en cours laurent
hamida notre cameraman qui se trouve là
bas m'a appelé il ya quelques minutes
pour nous dire que des responsables de
l'équipe casino était en train de sortir
des valises d'un bus et la police
judiciaire est arrivé a dit police
nationale perquisition messieurs ne
touchait plus à rien donc deux
perquisitions toujours en cours à
l'équipe on sait ici à l'hôtel novotel
avec l'équipe casino à challes pour
l'équipe de la française des jeux se
terminer
l'otan perd une question encore les
coureurs parle beaucoup des conditions
de ces perquisitions et interrogatoires
vous êtes témoins de ces perquisitions
comment cela se passe-t-il
visiblement assez calmement et écouter
ce que je peux vous dire ici au château
candy où se trouve l'équipe on ne sait
quand les renforts de crs sont arrivés
les soigneurs de l'équipe les
mécaniciens de l'équipe dont on sait ont
très mal perçu l'arrivée de ces renforts
de serre et si l'on parlait de police de
dictature il ya eu pendant quelques
instants un moment de tension pour le
reste à l'intérieur de l'hôtel tous
passent calmement la perquisition ici
dans les bus
on ne sait se déroule tout à fait
normalement on a entendu simplement le
manager de l'équipe abel anton hurlé au
téléphone il ya quelques minutes
pour le reste tout est calme
merci claude courset toutes dernières
informations et bien sûr d'autres
informations dans notre dernier journal
la course le tour de france est donc en
question ce soir la question est
véritablement posée repartira-t-il
demain à priori oui si les choses se
passent dans le calme comme cela a l'air
d'être le cas pour le moment mais on ne
doit pas encore apporté de réponse
définitive à l'heure qu'il est retour
maintenant sur cette journée folle et
triste à la fois de ce tour de france
qui s'étaient échappés qui était revenu
au sport pendant deux jours dans les
alpes et qui a été rattrapé aujourd'hui
par les différentes affaires de dopage
laurent frédéric bollée 14h50
visiblement quelque chose se prépare sur
la route du tour de france
nous sommes au km 32 de la 17e étape
dans la commune de saint jorioz le
peloton vient de mettre pied à terre
la situation est confuse voitures de
direction spectateurs touristes et
coureurs sont là ensemble
mêlée dans ce qui ressemble à une
gigantesque pagaille au milieu le
maillot jaune qui finalement repart
après 17 minutes d'arrêt mais les
coureurs effectuent alors un geste
symbolique très fort ils arrachent leurs
dossards et l'on apprend que laurent
jalabert et l'équipement de ces ne sont
pas repartis ils ont abandonné le tour
de france
quelques minutes plus tard jean marie
leblanc s'adresse par radio à petit à
carabane 15h45 bjarne riis le porte
parole du peloton revient parlé à jean
marie leblanc
la perquisition et les auditions des tvn
la veille d'autres sans doute le soir ne
passe toujours pas manifeste notre
révolte
et bon
on peut plus continuer comme ça on a
essayé de rendre la course assez belle
de la relance et par les exploits
sportifs et malgré tout ça tous les
jours tous les matins tous les soirs il
ya quelque chose de nouveau qui vient
pas tout détruire
non mais je pense que c'est très grave
là c'est vrai que les coureurs en ont
marre de ce qui se passe après les
étapes et là je pense qu'il faut
vraiment faire quelque chose 15h56 ce
quelque chose c'est un nouvel arrêt du
peloton on est avant le 50e kilomètre de
l'étape le tour est au bord du chaos
les discussions sont parfois vives entre
les coureurs
bjarne riis le danois veut des garanties
quant aux éventuels émission jean marie
leblanc clôture l'étape aille jusqu'à
aix les bains
16h03 de nouveau le peloton reprend la
route mais sans deux autres équipes
après les on sait les banesto irisé
sportive ne remonte pas sur le vélo
l'ambiance sur le bord de la route
devient dès lors surréaliste mais public
applaudit et s'ils arrêtent même parfois
les coureurs la conclusion est extrême
mais un à un les forçats de la route
comme on les appelle souvent passent et
continue une étape qui ne sert plus à
rien c'est une journée terrible pour le
tour les nerfs sont à vif
l'atmosphère pesante
19h25 c'est enfin l'arrivée à
aix-les-bains symboliquement bien sûr le
peloton est resté groupé mais surtout ce
sont quatre coureurs de l'équipe tv n
qui ont pris place devant les autres
ces quatre coureurs entendu contrôlé
hier soir par les autorités et que le
reste du peloton entend défendre le
soutien est fort l'équipe c'est une
grande famille le tour dans la tourmente
le tour dans l'incertitude d'une
situation fluctuante vous l'avez compris
est les toutes dernières informations
dans le journal de la nuit qui vous sera
présenté par thierry thulliez dans un
instant la météo nathalie rihouet je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
notre chaîne bonsoir album